hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to off I'm sorry for
the delay in this episode I am currently
away at Comic Con and I've been meeting
so many amazing fans and it's so
heartwarming to hear the whoa what the
hell is going on here we just entered a
new area in John 3 and things don't seem
to be going very well for the batter or
they're going exactly how they thought
they were gonna go but either way it's
been so amazing to see all the fans come
up to be comic-con there have been so
many more this year than ever before and
it's so heartwarming to hear all the
stories that you guys have to tell me
and when people say that my videos have
helped them through tough times in May
them laughs oh okay
something is very wrong here oh my
goodness gracious I have no idea what's
happening this is about to tell a
heartwarming story about how my fans are
awesome and I don't think that it's
going very well right now
either way this place is really really
strange we're trying to figure out the
secret of the sugar and I don't think
that this heartwarming story is gonna
get me anywhere okay alrighty then well
anyway I am in a hotel right now and I'm
trying to keep somewhat to an even keel
here and not go too loud because I don't
want to bother anybody else in the hotel
rooms and it's already getting pretty
late and I just got back from ninja sex
parties concert here in Petco Park and I
don't know if I want to fight you dude I
don't even wanna go okay no I'm just
gonna wanna go in here oh it's a brick
wall well fire right then why not let's
just see what you gotta go
yours is the most disturbing
yes I've ever seen in my life not you in
particular I fought these enemies before
obviously I should have done a scan to
see if it was any different than he was
before I don't think he would have been
but I just wanted to make sure but
either way I just got back from ninja
sex parties concert and oh my goodness
that rocked my frickin face off I would
pay to see ninja sex party tour around
the nation they are a fantastically
hilarious sexy show that you all need to
see no doubt about it you need to see it
and I need to figure out why the hell
any of this is actually happening I'm
gonna go back
because there was another way than I I
saw that it could have gone God the
batter looks weird when he's walking I
really did question why the batter's
doing any of this or what his motivation
really is hello friend how did I miss
you oh it's one of you Queenie kings I'm
just gonna knock that crown off your
head and then I'm gonna be on my way but
either way I'm trying to tell a whole
bunch of things at once I'm not even
thinking about what I'm doing here um
well here's okay here's the deal
I was that ninja sex party a concert in
Petco Park and you guys have just been
amazing the amount of people that have
come up and said hi to me you know the
loving stories and everything that
they've done I spent three days straight
non-stop not even taking a bit of a
break meeting fans and I still know that
I haven't been able to get you to you
also everyone who's in here in San Diego
that hasn't been able to find me please
come find me in booth 2 635 is why I'm
doing this you know this is why I'm
recording videos in a hotel room trying
to play a game and make it a little bit
entertaining for you guys and I'm gonna
save that for a little bit later okay
that's locked
I got a staircase over there another
goober gabber over there whoa a Friday
has been found cool what does a Friday
do I guess that'll be the last people of
equipment for my new day oh he has a
Thursday who doesn't have a day
ah here we go ah beneficial to
competences well then I guess that's
good enough but maybe I would want to
get that the batter hey the way we'll
see what goes on later yeah it's just
been so hard warming to see you guys and
all the things that you've done I'm
gonna finish this guy off all that music
is so weird why did it change from its
normal almost happy jazzy feel to this
ever since I killed that critic burnt
things have just gone horribly wrong
I think I did something terribly bad and
I discovered something that I was not
supposed to do and I have a feeling that
the banners actual objective he's not
what I want to know but either way I've
already come this far and I need to
purify the rest of them they all need to
be purified no exceptions okay let's go
down these stairs and see what's down
there but I just got a harp again
because it's so cool to be here once
again amongst you got oh it's you why
are you here what are you going to save
me mmm I may have some malicious advice
to relieve your mental suffering due to
a wrong dosage of difficulty but this
time it's not for free I'm looking for a
particular object which should be around
here somewhere bring me this intriguing
item and I will open the doors of Co
Nations okay thank you so much for all
your help I don't even know what your
name is anymore but yeah it being one on
one with fans again you know I haven't
had that experience in a long time Oh
and I didn't know that you respond hang
on man is that just gonna be the battle
music from now on because that is going
to be horrifyingly disturbing for the
rest of this game something has changed
something has definitely shifted in
everything in this game and why was that
guy oh they're all there again okay so I
just need to avoid him cuz otherwise I'm
just gonna be fighting him over and over
again and I don't know wait no they're
not all there what the hell is going on
here I have no idea but I need to find
the item but and again I keep getting
distracted these books are about sugar
these books are about sugar
I don't need sugar oh hello whoa enter
your password what are you talking about
Oh what excuse me I have no idea what is
going on in this game this game got so
frickin weird so freaking fast it was
already a little trippy and then it just
took a turn for the worst and I don't
know how we're ever gonna get back to it
okay but I am I'm really trying to talk
with you guys here and it's getting more
and more deranged as I go down but
seriously having that one-on-one
experience that I haven't had oh my yeah
it's wasting me okay hello
you seem very nice I'm gonna smash your
face in with a bad let me get a scan on
you before I do that
oh so you're quick to the attack hostile
burn malicious employee of area for no
weaknesses or resistances I'm just gonna
attack him until he dies hopefully
that'll be fine oh my god no no
no no no no
Oh Oh kill it kill it kill it Oh kill it
with wire what in the world was that I
can't exactly be loud here because I am
in a hotel room but I do not know no no
no no no no when you get back in the
head you get back in that mouthy [ __ ]
you get the hell back in there
you set up a [ __ ] I do not want
anything to do with you ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever that can go to hell
and burns forever and ever forever I
don't wanna know why was it coming out
of his mouth what in the world are you
and why do your legs feel stiff oh no no
no no
no no no no no no get back in there get
back in there I don't want to hear you I
don't want anything to do with you Jesus
fall over and die because I think he am
done with your ball so anyway once as
soon as I get done with this guy I'm
gonna talk about how heartwarming and
everything that everything going on in
the world of Comic Con is going to be
for me and how you guys do the best fans
in the world and I'm going to have
nightmares for the rest of my life
aren't I
oh that guy's almost yet I didn't even
notice that I was too distracted by that
freaky head coming out of his face just
use an object your fortune ticket hey yo
you're all better now and goodbye maybe
I got a low okay no I don't I do not
have to let that out thankfully what the
hell why was that coming out of his face
yeah this City belongs to us okay good
for you a music box has been found is
that what no no no you stay away from me
you douche okay but okay finally I'm
going to talk about this I'm gonna try
to avoid any weird conflicts that are
coming but you guys have been so
absolutely amazing to be here and just
hearing the stories that you guys have
told and getting to know you guys wanted
more because at the end of the day you
know a lot of people think of me as
youtuber buying the screen but I'm
actually just I'm one guy I'm one guy
that loves to make these videos for you
and I want you guys to know how much I
care about what you do for me and it's
just amazing to see that you guys can
respond in that way for me as well
because I wouldn't be here without you
guys and I wouldn't be able to do this
and I wouldn't be able to entertain you
guys or like try to give you guys well
the best content that I can every single
day without that in breach appreciation
that I'm able to feel and you guys have
given it to me in droves here and I just
can't even begin to say how grateful I
am for the opportunities you've given me
and you guys are absolutely awesome in
every way so thank you for that
and okay I finally finished what I was
trying to say since the beginning of
this episode and I'm sorry that took me
so long but I am finally back in
business and okay there we go
trying to upgrade my equipment so this
is gonna take a second but just again
God you guys are literally the best fans
you make me feel so appreciated
especially for you know what what we've
accomplished here as far as charity
working and the ability to make a
significant difference in you know
everything that we've done you know
every single time we do a charity event
it is unbelievably successful and you
know we sold it out in the most recent
when we sold 4,400 shirts or so
something like that and that's
outstanding especially for something
that I organized very quickly and you
know it wasn't very well run in my
opinion it could have been a lot better
but you guys were there and you guys
supported me and it's that support that
keeps me going so just thank you for
everything and you know I want to do
more of these things so that we can be
around and and you know able to you I
want you guys to get to know me because
it's weird when you you guys you guys
know me and I want to get to know you
because you guys see me here on this
channel every day some of you every
single day and that's incredible but at
the same time I don't get to know you
guys you know you guys are always out
there behind a screen for me I never get
to meet you want to want except for
these occasions and just being here is
just so cool but anyway I'm I'm done
dribbling I'm done drew let's get back
into this weird SK my I'm finished with
editing my god and Ray I finished with
editing my equipment now I'm 100%
focused on off and whatever the hell is
happening right here so I got the coltan
flesh and these lovely guys are
wandering the halls all Wibbly Dibley
and they're gonna stay there they didn't
get their sugar and they're very unhappy
about it nope nope think you know
I'm plenty leveled up I don't need
anything from you I am going to be just
fine without any input from you at least
that's a good idea I haven't saved up in
a while I don't know if I did something
specifically wrong but this zone was
going perfectly happy until I started
following mr. cat face man over there
into a land of nightmares so I need to
go back this way because I think the
music box is probably what that guy
wanted and that means that I'm gonna be
able to progress what does he want
why is the judge there why is his name
the judge what is he doing and why did
he merge with a humanoid well it reminds
me of like how the bird infected his
brother oh but what we have here
wouldn't that be music box I must admit
that this object interests me highly to
possess it is a desire very close to my
heart would you agree to entrust it to
me in exchange for a valuable clue wait
a minute I have a choice here what if I
say no
oh he just shuts up and goes away well I
don't know if it's what I'm supposed to
do but it's the only thing I can do yeah
beautiful beautiful which is a smoothly
conducted business now but Yuri is
widely in listen attentively to this
welcome advice of mine in the game
folder your browser will find the file
read you what it's not an its name is
not innocent
I'd suggest an active acidic reading
that is all one the world of xanthine
what does that mean and I'm gonna get to
the bottom of this I have no idea I need
to get to the readme file but I'm gonna
save the game before I do that I could
probably just exit out of the game but
at the same time I'm recording the
screen right now so just give me give me
a second to figure out how I'm gonna do
this I don't know if I did something bad
or
good but I'll be back okay so I don't
know if you guys can read this but I'm
gonna or if this is turning out right
for you bye got the text up here and I'm
gonna try to read through it real quick
to see if there's anything interesting
here that I may have missed
can one go to Alma close this file and
play to see what when oh there is one
any super close so unlock stuff I got it
okay that makes sense down left up right
zjb DB start oh my god
how do i unlock the secret ending
whistle whistle I don't know what that
means
if a cue means funfair in question what
does mean oh my
this is so weird this is so weird this
is so weird oh my god okay so I got it I
gotta remember this particular
instruction right here okay back to the
game I think I can put this down here
and I'm should be able to play again
without anything going horribly wrong I
am still recording so hopefully this is
gonna work oh my god that is so good
that was been there the whole time I did
not read the readme I did not read the
readme I swore I didn't have to give him
the music box I didn't have to give him
the music box I could have just done
that myself oh but I'm already stuck so
down left up
what no come on come on come on
crap come on
there we go right oh god what the hell
is is he
I don't know nosey is what the hell Z uh
Z J be e be sorry
dammit this is gonna take me a while
okay um guys I'm actually gonna do a
little bit of fibbing here because I
feel like giving the judge I feel like
giving him the music box was probably a
bad idea so what I'm gonna do is I'm
actually gonna go back I'm gonna quit
out I'm gonna go back before I gave him
the music box because I don't feel like
that was something I was supposed to do
I feel like I should have known
beforehand and then now that I have the
music by still I should be able to do
what I needed to do I still have the
music box or oh no there's a wrong safe
hang on one second I'm gonna go out I'm
actually going to get it before I do the
music box and hopefully that's going to
be good for me but if it isn't I have no
idea what I'm supposed to do okay so I
still have the music box
good Zachary was the owner of the park
was that one of Zachary I don't know
anyway I'm gonna carry on there's got to
be something else here that I'm missing
so I'm gonna keep looking around for it
there was a number of rooms here that I
could go in and I'm wondering if there
might have been something here and
there's this oh there was a note on this
desk I knew that I needed it yeah yes
yes push it through yes
oh that was that was war I knew there
was something to this ah oh
exactly oh my god I gotta write that
down but I don't have anything write it
down with an there's something in my eye
okay I just gotta remember this okay so
this must be the layout on the button of
the controller so the top one is Z the
left one is J so it's j z BD okay got it
z is up top z j BD okay got it got it
got it got to get the kid to got to got
to get to get out I can do ii do this i
don't need to give him the music box i
can keep the music box for myself and
then i'll never ever ever ever ever have
to give it away zj b d gotta gotta gotta
got a okay so the code is whoops no
that's not right so the code is
uh down no no no no left up j b d b
there we go access to the lower level
authorized perfect now I just got to
figure out where the hell I need to go
for the lower level and I'll be golden
forever I don't need to give him no
stinkin music box some music box belongs
to me those dead end down here that
might be where it is
weirdo no apparently not okay so there's
gotta be somewhere else that there's a
music or music box a lower level area
I'm not I don't trust Sakura I do not
like him I think he's a shady character
and I think he needs to go to hell okay
so I wonder if things have gone bad in
the other areas did everyone get
deprived of their sugar I'm just gonna
go back real quick and see if everything
else is as screwed up as here okay no
not that everything wasn't exactly
screwed up but at least is a little
because he's at least it's the same as
it was before and I didn't totally
bonkers up everything so I've got to
find it I gotta find okay excuse me
sorry there's something in my I am very
sure okay so I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
explore around I need to find with lower
areas are actually let me go talk with
Zack you Zachary I'm not gonna give him
the thing but now that I've already
solved the puzzle maybe he has something
else to say I don't know hello Zachary
you idiot I hate you um uh no go to hell
and stay there forever and ever and ever
until I can solve what I need to do be
right back guys I'll find what I need to
do oh here it was I'm an idiot I walked
right through this I didn't even see
this it okay well that's a nice sound
executive suites notes you must not be
here well in fact I am you must not be
here you must be holding this is a
warning oh my god I think this is a
serious warning oh my goodness oh I have
done so bad well it's upside down so the
puzzle is easy five three six two five
eight and see easy enough for you and me
but is there something else that it was
almost too easy
oh good say before I need to go anywhere
else maybe I should save here
but I don't know am I supposed to go
back oh oh before I do this before I do
this this might be something that I
can't change let me do so just I screwed
something up I'm not gonna be able to
get back there easily am i maybe I am
maybe I won't but someone said this was
important someone said that I missed
there was a secret boss in Zone one that
I missed um in a room with one of the
numbers in it or one of the rooms with
numbers in it I'm gonna go back and I'm
gonna find it because I'm not gonna miss
out anything on this player oh I think
it's a nice day outside
well that doesn't make any sense quite
peculiar quite peculiar huh well you
don't think anything's nice mr. batter
man okay so someone said that there was
a secret boss somewhere around here
quite peculiar yep quite peculiar indeed
uh-huh so zone zero has a nice day huh
I'm gonna find you what are you doing to
me no no oh I already know I know I know
I know I know I know I know I know I
know I know in here in here stairs how
did I miss that how did I miss the
stairs how did I miss the stairs
oh hello you're one of the monsters from
dead space you're one of the monsters
from dead space and there's this one on
the floor and you're guarding on the
sugar I'm ignoring why everything's so
frightening I'm never hungry mmm pick up
something beautiful really hard and
maybe you will see it tomorrow who are
you like a beautiful day for example
with a huge duckie a frightening one
what are you doing here let's not lose
any time - useless introductions
let's tense my dear friend hmm
okay then Oh see you're not one of the
masses but I'm still gonna purify you
just the same I'm gonna analyze krappa
to you you have little ducky galaxies
orbiting you that's how you gross okay
why don't know why you're having so many
things why okay stop that please
sugar his name is literally sugar why
and what's on his nipples or does he
just have or he she'll have aa dummy -
oh so he has dummies uh well they get to
die just the same bonkers and everyone
gets oh I did hit you I guess I couldn't
have killed you without the last one
because all your dummies wouldn't
bye-bye okay that would hurt Oh moe mega
seems to be in madness so he can't seem
to do anything that's okay all of your
dummies have gone their little sugar
it doesn't matter Lee I'm at Amazon
maybe it does let me increase the
platters Otello that hurt a lot thank
you
what does omega gonna get out of madness
maybe alpha could give you a little bit
of a hand I really do feel bad because I
hope that my voice isn't carrying too
far outside the hotel and I hope that no
one actually minds what's going on here
in this place this policy mean why is
Omega also been oh that doesn't help it
at all well then I guess I'll Megas is
out of commission for a while donk this
may take a while because I don't know
what else I'm supposed to do he doesn't
actually hurt all that much but hey you
never know what did that even say excuse
me what did you call me
he said something French this is one of
your friend to tax because his game was
made by a Frenchman okay screw this
noise I'm actually just gonna use an
item and hopefully that's gonna be able
to get them cured up in no time
cuz I don't know how else I'm supposed
to do this this doesn't seem to work oh
man this fight is taking forever I've
already been fighting for about five
minutes straight here and I don't even
know if I'm making a dent in ER it's
been another five minutes of wailing on
this guy and I don't know how close I am
to the finish I've been doing this for a
long time now and so far nothing I've
gone through a lot of items rejuvenating
myself I've gone through a lot of items
getting more confidence points this is
gonna take a while I can already tell
and it's already taking a while so
hopefully we'll be done soon yes oh my
god yes finally holy crap that took
forever
thirty thousand full grand chocolate or
oh my goodness
Oh save the third base yes I don't long
Jane very good everyone levels up so
much oh I really way to go
I didn't like that too my dear friend
oh I'm sorry sugar
mmm I think the huge frightening ducky
has won this round
say goodbye to Sakura for me okay she's
dead okay so it was a she in the end
the ducky eh I have no idea what the
hell is going on in this game
oddly enough it seemed like a very
appropriate time to fight that boss dr.
Don I guess it's better like that what
do you even mean who you mean what do
you mean Oh
you even have better items now that I've
beaten him don't you
well good for you that's fantastic
I'm glad that you do I don't know what
you're up to man but I boastful signal
good very good
I don't know what you're up to man but I
don't like it mmm why do you say they're
there anyway I don't have enough credits
for you man but I can at least I got
better weapons ok so this will be the
end of this episode here hopefully by
the time I get to the next episode I
will be back home and able to play there
and able to record not in a hotel room
but hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
and once again I got to reiterate being
in Comic Con and meeting guys on an
individual level has been absolutely
fantastic I wish I could meet every
single one of you and it's so weird
because now that I've been to comic-con
three years now the first time I had two
thousand subs
the second time at about 500 thousand I
thought that was huge but now I have you
know 2.8 million subscribers and it's
just incredible and it's so kind of
nostalgic to get this feeling and I've
met some fans that I've met you know I
met him a year ago and it's weird
because it's like meeting an old friend
that I haven't seen in forever and it's
so cool so just seriously thank you guys
so much for everything that you've done
for me I'm gonna play this game again
this game is so weird to me but so much
fun and I hope you guys are enjoying
this so either way thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
ba-bye
you